you know my next guest from one tree
hill grey's anatomy
and white collar this summer she hosted
friday night in with the morgans on amc
with her husband jeffrey dean morgan
recently she traded the hollywood
spotlight for a simpler life on a farm
in upstate new york
she's written about that in her new book
the rural diaries it's out right now
let's bring her in here hilary burton
morgan how you doing how are you
i am so good oh my gosh it's so
beautiful where you are
i'm like trying to find a place where
there's not like kids or a mailman
or like destruction anywhere it's just
you know how it is that was literally me
in montana now i'm back in l.a but
literally every time i had to do my show
for montana i was like
how do i make this look like i was like
there's so much going on here right now
so much i think there's like a
lawn mower running somewhere it was
always a tractor or something
happening well i was just talking to al
roker actually i was i was literally
just talking to him and y'all are in the
same neck of the woods right
yeah yeah i think he's up here in the
hudson valley we um oh look there goes
my husband now
um yeah
he has no idea what we're doing um al
does a charity with us called big slick
in kansas city
and so that's the last time we saw him
we raised money for children's mercy
hospital out there and we talked about
being here
the thing about being in the hudson
valley though is that like this is where
you come to hide out so you don't ever
see anybody it's like that's where
that's why we went to montana for our
vacation
yeah so you're living on a farm and with
your kids so do you put them to work
oh my god all the time yeah yeah yeah
so much to get done right well there's
there's so much to get done
and i want them to be responsible that
was the thing we noticed in la is that a
lot of the kids that we would see on the
playground there weren't like
aware that there's other people on the
planet and so we want
kids to be grounded and have a lot to do
um and so we've put them to work whether
it's like
building the garden or you can hear all
the birds in the background myself i can
hear your rooster
dude my kids are on chicken duty um
we just i don't i have we have chickens
but i don't allow a rooster
i'm like oh gosh we've got such a bad
coyote and fox problem we need a boat oh
i got a field so i got you
killed that's awesome that you put your
kids to work that's the same thing that
my husband and i were doing we wanted
our kids to be able to actually because
i grew up in the countryside and so did
he
so is it true that you not only write
books over shoot a talk show
run a farm but you're also helping out
local hospitals
so many of our good friends here in the
hudson valley are
are members of the medical field you
know whether it's like doctors or nurses
or emts
and so the immediacy of helping all of
them was really important so we started
sewing masks right away
encouraging other people to sew masks we
um a lot of the moms
soccer moms we all got together and
started raising
money to feed all the medical workers at
our coveted testing facility
so now that same group of people we're
taking all that energy we had for the
pandemic
and we're putting it towards our school
teachers now because we have no idea
what school is going to look like in the
fall and our teachers can't afford
crayons
and paper and books and stuff for the
kids let alone
ppe for everybody to make it safe so
we're trying to
even thinking about like a lot of us
with kids
our kids they might still be home and a
lot of parents don't have access to all
those supplies
like a lot of you know so not every kid
has a computer or an
ipad um but your new book is about
your life up there and i think that it's
really cool so what
what inspired you to do is it because
basically you had that other lifestyle
and you wanted it slowed down a bit
like i mean you know we grew up and it
was like you're on tv
and you have to grow up in front of a
lot of people and you've got to project
this certain image
and so when i kind of took off working
to be a mom
i didn't do social media i didn't engage
in any of that
and i was encouraged to join social
media and what i
saw was just kind of unattainable
and super glamorous and it made me feel
bad
i didn't like i didn't like i felt like
i was missing out or that i wasn't
living up to some expectation
yeah so i started posting just really
like stripped down like here's the farm
kind of post some people responded to it
and so i wanted to write a love letter
to our community
and our lifestyle that glamorized like
the small beautiful noble lives that
take place when nobody's looking
um not everything has to be on a yacht
you know what i mean
yeah well what kind of animals do you
have on the farm well i've got
jeffrey jeffrey has corralled our new
baby chicken
oh hi what's up hey how are you
oh my gosh so cute i know you have um
chickens and and ducks like that ever
but what else do you have
well this one's the donkey whisperer he
spends all day brushing the donkeys in
the field here do you want to sit down
cuddle up dad um we've got alpaca we've
got a lot of
mini donkeys we rescue jack and diana
island cattle um and then every spring
we take in
uh cows from the local dairy farm
that we raise uh yearlings with their
moms
yeah so a cow calf operation okay cool
that's cool we get calls all the time
people are like oh this farm is closing
down we
pick our animals and so even if we can't
take them we try to hook them up with
other people who can
no that's so hilarious that happened to
me in texas i had a rescue ranch and
like literally
people were just dropping animals and i
was like okay there comes a point to
where
you have to be able to get to all of
them like you know so that's that does
happen but it's messed up
yeah you're like there's not a that's it
was me and my my sister and her family
and i was like uh there's not
people don't work here just us holding
it down
so so i mean this is so i would just
want to say
hi everybody okay obviously jeffrey dean
morgan has um
involved he's now involved in the
interview and i'm such a big fan i love
the walking dead so i'm just going to
say that shout out
um so thank you thank you for hanging
out with us but um
so hillary told us how special your
community is up there um what's your
favorite part about it she told us why
she kind of liked
living up there and out of the the
limelight i love it as well obviously we
have a place in
montana um but i want to know why you
like that kind of life and but also i
heard you owned a candy shop do you
still own a candy shop
yeah we do i i mean i think just getting
out of los
angeles for us was such it was so needed
i think just for our well-being
um and then having kids and it started
out with
obviously just the one gus and we
thought that this kind of lifestyle
uh was very conducive to raising a good
kid
uh and so far so good uh he's good for
now
he's alive he's breathing yeah yeah
he's pretty good and you know george is
a real uh animal whisperer too
it turns out so she her and i are the we
love our animals
gus and i are the gardeners they're the
animal people yeah she spends a lot of
time in the
chicken coops um she loves the chickens
for whatever she loves all the animals
but she loves the chickens like every
night it's a thing she has to be
has to have her chicken duck time that's
so cool too to have both worlds thank
you guys so much
for hanging out with us i love your
beautiful farm thank you for having us
um y'all be sure to pick up hillary's
new book the rural
diaries rural is hard for me to say
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going